damn movie you've got a spelling error
in your title and you didn't even notice
a theory or aberration you take that
back mother for my childhood dog scruffy
has this title okay I'm all for
establishing a mood but there are so
many panning shots of great Merkers in
this opening and I think we've covered
at least five different cemeteries /
cemeteries cemeteries
yeah sudden evil lair from the first
season of True detective hello not only
is this a family buys a creepy house and
will definately be haunted by two cliche
it's also a family in the 80s drives a
station wagon with wood paneling cliche
oh yeah what do you think the music the
longing looks the oversized grins and /
pronounced hugs this feels more like a
Douglas Sirk melodrama than a horror
movie
so does this asshole go around blowing
his horn everywhere he can't even see
anyone at the house when he leans into
that thing Louis crude ah hell Judds
gonna turn out to be Ivan Drago's
grandfather isn't he in the first eight
minutes of this film four of them have
been people talking about worth staring
at this path who gives a path that much
goddamn attention it's almost like these
characters know they're in a horror film
this is the first of what are far too
many animal based unnecessary jump
scares and they can write the hell off
what a weird movie manhood test isn't a
bottle just a glass that's bottle shaped
is Judd going to ask the docs opinion on
whether or not a hotdog is a sandwich
next and seriously what the hell is up
with this road maybe these trucks would
be traveling this often and this quickly
but why aren't there any normal cars
passing through - it's like there's a
fork a mile from here that says trucks
go this way and all other cars continue
at a normal speed down the non horror
movie lane you know that path your wife
commented on I'm pretty sure this movie
has the word path in it more times than
that Hulu show that was actually titled
the path that road
those are Rinku trucks the two main
reasons is that okay I don't Fred Quinn
is going forward with his axe in here
he's mainlining way too hard where does
it lead that's uh no time Wolcott as we
should adopt around my stomach pain so
bad guess I'll never be
okay hell I married anyone I mean is she
having three different conversations
with herself at the same time damn it
movie not everyone in a horror movie
needs to be weird and creepy
it says Pet Sematary honey it's
misspelled but that's what it says um
Missy waiting for a line prompt
seriously do these folks think this
suddenly turn into a silent film cat
sound even though the cat is clearly not
making a sound
wait they live right on the water look
how gorgeous that dish and the blather
has been super nice considering the
clothes right why are they so obsessed
with this goddamn cemetery instead of
playing around over there don't
shilly-shally Lois Julie Shelly
Jesus Christ doesn't the kid at least
have any lines here Oh nuts good yes if
you were playing the nuts cup drinking
game you would be buzzed enough now to
possibly enjoy the rest of the film uh
Fran stack is it just me there is this
scene been going on for like six hours
and thus begins the surprisingly
disgusting movie
I know it's based on a Stephen King
novel and everything but he's not always
this violent you didn't see like this in
Shawshank also did the entire class come
with this kid I'm sure he was popular
but this is a ridiculous amount of
support yeah that's definitely should be
asking instead of immediately trying to
help this boy that's miraculously still
alive also watching this performance
makes me think that not having Keanu
Reeves play the character in the new
version seems like a missed opportunity
no 80s running shorts 80 special effects
come on Doc don't make me tell you twice
what's with the impatience this asshole
disappeared as soon as he beckoned him
the first time and he didn't give Lois
any actual information also
it was freaked out when the cat scared
him a couple minutes ago he's just
taking this without batting an eyelash
you said you would leave me man I really
wanted to get their money's worth with a
makeup job on massive head wound Harry
huh this movie is seriously showing
almost the entirety of this king walk
the pacing and editing of this thing are
the worst parts and you know I mean that
after watching this guy's performance
this is the place with a damn speak yes
I know
because Judd told me this earlier why do
we need a victor when we've got any
perfectly alive judge Jesus even waking
up and this movie takes forever
holy dude even if the kids dead you
can't destroy his entire medical records
file are we sure this assholes a doctor
it's not like he's actually done any
doctoring on-screen despite all that
occurred right after they moved in
nothing happened between August and
November man this kids cute he's really
a breath of fresh air and calm
to the dark and dour ambience of the
rest of the film I'm glad he'll be
around for a while Oh wrong channel yep
that church all right did it really take
an up-close look and a rudimentary
medical exam to confirm this like is it
that hard to tell just from looking down
look I know it's November in Maine and
all but this dickhead has at least four
layers on like he walked into an Eddie
Bauer and said I'll take one of
everything
good what's that good question you want
to stare about it did Lewis seriously
agree to go rock climbing without any
questions about what they were doing
what is this place holy this place is
huge in fact I would argue too huge for
a not that many people know about its
site maybe we didn't have social media
in today's internet 1989 but we did have
planes from which this would have been
easily seen so this is Judds immediate
inclination to the problem of the dead
cat what about the sitcom solution of
getting a new one that looks a lot like
the old one which will fool the kid for
a little while but then they'll have the
dawning realization that it's not the
old one which will lead to a sit-down
between parent and child and a comically
frank discussion about the transience of
life then it's worth super popular in
the eighties
I'll tell you when would have been an
appropriate time to ask this sometime
during the hour that it took to walk
back from the burial ground happy
Thanksgiving guys hey fYI I found the
dead cat and buried it in magic and
everyone's gonna die because of it so
you'd be a drumstick dude he can't hear
you staring over the goddamn phone also
what's the deal with lewis's weirdness
here sure it was an unusual afternoon
but he didn't do anything that would
prevent him from talking to his son I
know this was 1989 but holy balls those
are some epically the dead cat effects
Cat Scratch bleeder I know but I still
went ahead and had you bury Church there
so let's hope for the best that's yeah
man don't feel the need to treat that
wound caused by your supernaturally
alive cat or bandage it or anything
despite the fact that you're you know a
doctor
[Music]
random Mi'kmaq burial ground shot is
truly random they're not taking Missy to
it so why was it shown and that was
clearly Louis with Church in a trash bag
and Judd with his digging devices
standing there from the previous day
if he doesn't count knew what he well
wow this is the weirdest Stan Lee cameo
I've ever seen my father used to have a
saying judge just look quietly bemused
all the time it'll make up for the fact
that you have a complete lack of acting
talent also make sure to work out a
bunch for the love of God take care of
that hair reading I wake up and I think
Ted yet she the Zelda storyline seems to
be the go-to for most fans of this movie
and to be fair the make up work and the
way it's shot should be commended but
the fact that it has all to do with the
rest of the movie should be sinned and
so we shall go see you hater Rachel and
that was true it's like Mary Lambert
thought the Phoebe Cates bar confession
and gremlins wasn't melodramatic enough
and knew she could top it doesn't make
it any better but to be fair she
succeeded I'm going to get you a valium
bitch you know I don't take tonight you
do of course Lois has a casual valium
prescription it explains a ton about
this performance so witness this
everyone's out here in summer clothes so
I guess it's been about a year since
they moved in and the children seriously
haven't aged a day I'm wondering if it's
possible to Telegraph a child's death
Annie
been harder than what's currently on my
screen everything spatially about this
scene makes no goddamn sense unless you
assume the two-year-old is Quicksilver
no seriously no I want no part of this
section of the movie it's a new and a
skip and a big ol queue for good measure
I knew something like this would happen
I told her when you were first married
you'll have all the grief you can stand
and more I said the hell is the problem
with Rachel's parents sure Lois is low
on personality but he's a fucking doctor
right it's not like she punched down
with looking for a husband I could take
it back if you wanted to to man the
things Ellie says really only makes
sense if she knows about the magic of
the mi'kmaq grounds but she doesn't know
this provides some convenient but
unwarranted reminders to Lois on how he
can handle this
[Music]
so this thing cool now it was
Thanksgiving when he performed the
resurrection and now it's well into the
next year
so for all those months he's been okay
enough to sleep in the bed but now it's
getting all creepy
you asked me of course it's been done I
don't understand why Lois ever believed
anyone who knew about that place would
immediately be at least thinking about
it once they lost a loved one and had to
be stopped for Fred Gwynne was doing
everything in his power to act this
movie up to his standards but I'll be
damned if it wasn't the most futile
effort I've ever seen don't think about
doing it Lois place goods oh yeah
it's a place evil then why are the hell
did Judd take him out there in the first
place I know he was trying to help Ellie
cope with church being dead but movie
simply cannot make up its mind on this
character I'm not sure why the movie
ever introduces The Sixth Sense subplot
with Ellie if it's never gonna use it
for anything other than to have her
mispronounce pass cow in a cute wig
damn it Dale fell asleep on the set
again in the middle of a scene someone
take those horse tranquilizers away from
him for God's sake great idea man if you
want to rob a grave you want to make
sure you start that in the middle of the
day I'll just put him back to sleep
there was no way Dale was gonna get into
an emotional state to cry on command but
luckily for the director he suffered a
massive allergy attack in the middle of
this tape that's why my wife won't leave
me alone anymore she knows I'll just
cheat on her with insane amounts of
ground beef and poultry goodbye Rachael
hey remember back in the days when this
silly dial tone sounds after the phone
is hung up on the other side cliche
happened all the time I guess it's a
prerequisite for horror movie characters
to be able to dig graves if you ask me
to dig a one-foot hole in my backyard
I'm not sure I could comply
[Applause]
that's right doc you outsmarted them
again solely by ducking into the grave
that you just dug man jet brings
Budweiser over to Lewis so frequently
I'm started to think he's a plant like
Marlon and The Truman Show baby corpse
did it did it baby
corpse did it do I never realized until
now how the people behind 2016's the boy
must have really loved this five-minute
section of Rachel's parents house and
thought well if there was an evil man
Bowie in the walls great can we watch
that movie instead Jesus in Christ the
nearly headless Nick character has now
gone from confusing to infuriating he's
got a seat on the plane now also why is
Rachel going back to Maine in such a
rush she has no idea about the
resurrection circle and the only thing
that has prompted this reaction was
Ellie knowing about the kid that died
earlier in the movie so there's no
reason for her to scurry back home what
just imagination now let's get back to
the very real business of raising your
eyes from the dead it's trying to stop
you do you hear me it's trying to stop
you so what exactly is the it that's
trying to stop Rachel Micmac Indians
spirit ghost of her sister Armas hey why
is this movie called Pet Sematary anyway
burial ground is like miles from the
actual cemetery and they only bring back
one animal in the entire movie Rachel is
lucky enough to get the one truck driver
who's not driving 150 miles an hour in
this movie
ding kids always leaving the door open
why is gate coming over here to mess
with Judd Judd specifically said
whomever did the burying essentially
becomes the owner if Judd was over at
the Creed's house and got in the way I
can see why gage would kill him but to
purposely go over to judge house to for
them doesn't seem to fit with the mcmac
undead scheme Gone with the Wind
thank you so much so Rachel just abandon
that rental car outside of Boston she
didn't stop to make a phone call to let
budget know or anything I mean who's the
real villain here it's the end of the
line for me too great still not sure how
you work or fit into this movie but safe
travels Jay Rachel race the hell back to
Maine - I guess check on Lewis so it
makes perfect sense that she immediately
goes over to Judds place I don't care if
she heard a noise or not she was
previously absurdly focused on getting
home are you okay I don't know but if
this movie holds for my bet it will show
your entire and journey up those steps
now the demon or ghost or what the can
change forms just
with anyone that encounters that totally
explained earlier in the movie yep just
over here staring you know normal
Tuesday so now the demon learn how to
use the fucking phone holy this movie
has gone off the fucking rails you just
shoved the entire syringe into that cat
clearly damn it kiff surprised himself
by not acting like he was waking up
after a long coma
look there's building tension in a
horror movie and then there's the
criminally drawn out boat that this
movie's constantly serves us without
these long shots of nothingness this
thing would be just under an hour
lots of seconds of Lois getting attacked
by a discount Chucky doll this is what
I've been constantly saying to Chris for
putting this movie on the schedule and
making me watch it movie didn't even try
to hide that it's just the doll sitting
there not even gonna pretend to give the
viewer a suspension of disbelief I'm so
sorry but don't make it worse oh hey
it's that guy again but didn't he'd
clearly say that he wasn't allowed to go
any further in this story when Rachel
got back did he could it reprieve for
good behavior so no one even with all
these trucks passing by called in the
massive house fire what you own always
comes home dear or goes to your
neighbor's house and kills him for no
reason at all yeah thank god that's over
it's not like they bring the actual
movie back from the dead and resuscitate
this those woods belong to something
else
well in 20 years they could become
steady viewers programming for cats -
what what was that word what would -
what did you say Utes yeah - Utes what
is a ute I just came Wesley
no one wants to become dependent that
happens later but it does happen
so why do people start on my home planet
there was so much poverty and violence
that for some the only Escape is through
drugs
how can a chemical substance provide an
escape it doesn't but it makes you think
it does what's put a smile on that face
who the fuck is Martha Stewart hell I
married anyone it's good talking damn it
man I'm a doctor I'm not a vet your
mother sucks cocks in hell did you just
order laughs in a diner yeah why because
it's a diner